[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola para empezar me gustaría pedirles
el favor de que levanten sus manos
ahora los que creen que no hay nada
bueno en el duelo o algo y que solamente
algo negativo por favor baila
gracias
bueno hola mi nombre es y sin a ferrero
soy colombiana bogotá nada para vida
soy hija de natalia quintero y de
mauricio ferrero williamson
y mi papá falleció hace un poco más de
tres años
le dio una infección pulmonar progresiva
y desde que falleció
y mis papás eran separados así que yo
vivía con mi mamá
y no ella mi papá mucho porque muchas
veces estaba en el hospital y muchas de
estas veces tampoco lo podía ver porque
estaba en cuidados intensivos y no me
permitían verlo
falleció en 2015
yo soy catalina saavedra soy hija de
leslie sánchez y hugo saavedra mi mamá
también fallece hace un poco más de tres
años debido a un cáncer con el cual
luchó dos años
durante estos dos años yo también tuve
que visitar mucho tiempo en mamá en la
clínica o muchas veces simplemente
estaba en la casa pero no era ella pues
estaba enferma y estaba en tratamiento
de quimioterapia y pues no la podía ver
como mamá entera
bueno entonces qué pasó después de que
perdimos a nuestros padres llegamos al
colegio después de unas semanas de
sentirnos en un cuerpo que no era
nuestro y lo que pasó fue que la gente
nos miraba con los ojos ya no éramos ni
cristina ni catalina si le damos la niña
que había perdido a la mamá y la línea
que había perdido el papá esta
experiencia lo que hizo fue poner una
etiqueta y la gente nos empezó a tener
pesar
nos pareció increíble que las personas
no pensaban que podíamos seguir adelante
que al estar felices no estábamos
cumpliendo con la parte de haber perdido
una persona tan cercana como lo es un
padre una madre entonces lo que queremos
hacer en verdad hoy es mostrarles que
hay un lado positivo de perder a una
persona y que no es solamente algo
negativo de lo que no se puede salir
y de hecho está acá hablándoles a
ustedes en esta charla me acuerda mucho
a mi papá porque él fue el que me
introdujo el tema te tapones lo conocí
porque me acuerdo que a él le encantaba
verlos ted talks y yo muchas veces me
sentaba con él a verlos entonces estar
acá es una manera muy linda de
recordarlo
pero bueno entonces para saber qué es el
duelo y conocerlo más porque sé que
algunos de ustedes acá puede que no
hayan pasado por el duelo necesitamos
entender las dimensiones del cuerpo
humano
y entonces la primera es la biológica
qué es
nuestros sentidos las cosas físicas
nuestros órganos etcétera la segunda es
la sociedad en ésta está nuestro entorno
y cómo nos relacionamos con él y con
nosotros mismos
la siguiente es la psicológica y es la
de como pienso como analizo las cosas
las que nos permite tener un pensamiento
crítico y conocer conceptos abstractos
la última y la más importante para
nuestra charla de hoy es la espiritual
ésta nos diferencia de todo el resto de
los seres vivos es la que nos hace pues
personas aquí va nuestra relación con la
religión y nuestra fe pero pues más
importante no el duelo entonces el duelo
es un conocimiento que adquirimos en
nuestra dimensión espiritual
y una comparación con el duelo son las
matemáticas
yo sé que estarán pensando que tienen
que ver las matemáticas con el duelo
nada que ver pero las matemáticas se
manifiestan de una manera muy similar al
duelo cuando nos enseñan
las matemáticas nos enseñan uno más uno
es dos dos más dos es cuatro y al
principio nos cuesta mucho entender este
concepto y sé que muchos de acá también
se les hace muy difícil lo que pasa con
el duero es muy similar cuando perdemos
a una persona a la cual queremos mucho
al principio no entendemos que está
pasando y se nos hace hasta más fácil
negarlo por completo pero después de un
tiempo cuando ya lo entendemos es un
conocimiento espiritual que adquirimos
que nos permite resolver futuros
problemas futuros duelos y nos enseña
autocompasión y auto consuelo
entonces qué es esto que nosotros
sacamos positivo de esta situación que
nuestra sociedad ve tan negativa lo que
yo más aprendí de esta experiencia que
adquirí fue apreciar más las relaciones
con las personas en mi familia siempre
había habido un balance entre que la
personalidad de mi papá y la de mi
hermana son muy parecidas y mi
personalidad con la de mamá eran muy
parecidas
incluso cuando pequeña y aún hasta ahora
me dicen mini nena y era el apodo que le
decían a mamá y en ese momento o pues
cuando yo ya tenía un poco más de edad y
mi mamá se ya conmigo ese apodo no
significaba nada pero ahora es un total
orgullo entonces lo que yo saqué fue que
al haber perdido en mamá entiendo mejor
cómo apreciar las relaciones que tengo
con las personas y como puede que haya
valorado ese balance entre mi familia
pero nunca le di la importancia que se
merecía
desde mi experiencia con el duelo pues
aprendí muchas cosas pero una de las que
más me dejó marcada fue apreciar todos
los momentos con las personas que
queremos porque muchas veces damos todo
por hecho y pensamos que todo lo vamos a
tener toda la vida cuando no es verdad
ayer perdió a mi papá me enseñó que
todos los momentos son muy preciados por
más insignificantes que parezcan
cuando mi copa estaba vivo muchas veces
me decía
chris vamos a la finca o a comernos un
helado o acompañarme a esto y yo
pensando que tenía toda la vida para
hacer estas cosas con él muchas veces
dije que no y no fue hasta que se
acabaron totalmente esos momentos que me
di cuenta que ella nunca los más los iba
a tener
entonces por favor quiero que todos se
levanten de sus sillas
los que definitivamente piensan que no
se puede sacar nada nada bueno en perder
una persona se pueden sentar
y para concluir queremos decir que
estamos muy orgullosos de haber sido y
ser hijas de leslie sánchez y mauricio
ferrero que nos formaron mucho durante
nuestra crianza pero aún más con su
partida muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]